Your idea of realer than real appears to
parallel Plato's theory of the forms?
Is this the source of the idea or are
you reconsidering ancient philosophy?
Well,
God only knows what the source of an
idea is,
you know,
um,
uh,
my sense of Plato's forms was it was
that they weren't exactly narrative
instructure although I think that,
I think that there isn't at least an
analogous relationship between the idea
of archetype and the idea of form.
Um,
I think Plato was talking more about
forms of,
of tangible objects in the world.
You know,
where I'm talking more about permanent
patterns of behavior,
you know,
because,
okay,
what are,
what our culture is essentially is a
dance of permanent patterns of behavior.
I mean,
there's a fair bit of variability in
the,
in the patterns.
Like there is variability in a
basketball game or a soccer game or
something like that.
You know,
there's obviously predictability and
variability,
but,
um,
what's the predictable elements are the,
are equivalent in some sense to the
platonic forms,
which is the point that you're making
and it's the discovery of those more
permanent forms that emerges.
As a consequence of the spinning of
stories,
you know,
because we're watching each other
constantly and we're articulating what
we see and then we're amalgamating the
articulations and we're sifting them
for,
for fundamental patterns.
Like a good example of that.
It's something I just recently
discovered when I did the biblical
lectures on Abraham.
You know,
I,
I didn't understand that Abraham was a
late bloomer.
You know,
he was like the guy who stayed in his
mother's basement for too long.
I mean,
he's 75 when God calls him on an
adventure and God basically tells him to
leave his family and his countrymen and
his kinsmen and to go into the land of
the stranger.
And that's,
see there's an archetypal pattern there.
And the pattern is,
while it's the pattern of the call and
it's,
it's deeply,
it's something that people experience,
you know,
like an adolescent,
a healthy adolescent wants to get away
from his or her stultifying,
uh,
um,
dependent upbringing and go out into the
world of adventure,
you know,
in,
in the biblical stories,
thoughts that's symbolically represented
as something akin to a divine call,
which,
which I think is quite interesting
because,
you know,
we don't understand these calls.
You know,
you have an impulse to do something,
something captures your interest,
something captures your motivation.
It's,
it's not like it's self-generated.
Exactly.
You know,
the,
that the call to adventure is produced
by something like a transcendent deity
is a really interesting idea.
Now.
It depends on what you mean by,
I didn't know you could think about it
as an ancient brain circuit,
I suppose.
Although I don't know if that really
makes it things any clearer.
But there is an impulse within people
that pulls them out into the world to go
away from their safe circumstances and
to make their fortunate where there's
famine and tyranny and,
and threats to the integrity of the
family,
which are all things that Abraham
immediately encounters when he listens
to God.
And so that seems to be something like
something that's realer than real
because everyone experiences that to
some degree or everyone can relate to
it.
It's a deep,
deep theme.
And you know,
what I'm looking for in the biblical
stories,
in other mythological representations is
these deep universal themes.
Now is that a reconceptualization of
ancient philosophy?
It's really hard to say because,
you know,
I derived the idea of the archetype,
at least in part from reading young and
young of course,
was influenced because he had a great
classical education by the ancients.
And so exactly where these ideas come
from isn't clear.
So,
um,
so I guess that's pretty much all I,
all I have to say about that.